anybody who's been watching my stuff for
a while know that my interests are kind
of all over the place
pretty much anything with the geeky bent
to it but really if i were to
say if there's one true love that i
really have
i am an animation junkie so this little
sub series is going to be delving into
the world of animation the best the
worst
the stuff i love the stuff i think's
overrated so let's get right to it
starting with
geeks around my age know this show and
they love this show with good
reason batman the anime series really
paved the way for this show and it's
gorgeous animation there's a lot of
action in the show and the action kicks
a whole lot of ass
but at its heart it's dealing with some
pretty heavy stuff it's dealing with
family loss betrayal it gets
shakespearean at points very
blatantly in fact so on top of
everything else it's surprisingly well
educated
and the voice cast is stellar i think
keith david is a freaking
god due in no small part to his work as
goliath this is what introduced me to
the guy he is so good and he's got such
gravitas to his voice it's
i mean it's almost unparalleled it's
james earl jonesian
and he's such a strong lead character
but he's got these great characters
around him too elisa who could have been
just a
tag along a damsel in distress like
april o'neil or something but no
she's strong she's independent she could
take care of herself xanato's
really fascinating villain not only
because he's not
really that much of a bad guy yeah he's
out for himself and he's got a lot of
schemes but
you know he's not just evil you know
mustache twirling evil he's got layers
he's complicated
demona oh tragic villain you want to
talk
about a bad history this chick oh man
by the time the show ends you completely
get why she is the way she is
and the other gargoyles are great too
hudson broadway brooklyn bronx
all these guys and they're just such a
family you really get that feeling of
community in this show i feel like i'm
finally able to talk about this thing
completely because
volume two of season two finally did
come out we had to wait a long long time
for that because the first two didn't
sell up to expectations but finally
they did they threw the fans a bone and
they gave us this thing so i feel i can
do the whole scope
yes i understand there were more
episodes even after seasons two they
were called the goliath chronicles but
the creator of the show is just owned
them and generally they're not
considered canon so i'm not even gonna
deal with that but the progress of this
show i mean season one you immediately
just
by the fact that it delves right off the
bat
into this history and this depth of of
all this stuff going on in scotland and
the history of these characters
and then you get a lot of really bold
mysteries in the first season because
you get macbeth introduced who isn't
going to get explained for quite a while
but it is interesting right off the bat
john reese davies another voice shout
out i think
season 2 vol one is probably uh most of
my favorite stuff it just gets
really in-depth and we get a lot of
great stuff with the history of
demona and macbeth and you get to see
all these other characters just grow and
change and evolve
season two volume two i'm actually a
little bit iffy on because
it expands the world but it expands the
world
so much that it kind of makes the
gargoyles themselves seem
a little bit more minor in a weird way
because when the show
started the whole sort of hook and the
pitch was these gargoyles are the only
ones of their kind and the world that
they were once a part of is gone
well season two volume two material we
start finding out well there's avalon
there's other gargoyles
there's all these other sort of mystical
beings and the gargoyles themselves just
feel a little bit less special because
of that it's still great stuff don't get
me wrong but you know it's a it's a
personal preference thing
but this show is just top notch it's
gorgeous animation i would recommend it
really for
anybody i would say age seven or eight
and going up from that
they have to be able to cope with the
idea of characters actually dying
because there is some
actual death in this show it's not
traumatic
characters you love don't die but when
dealing with a lot of the backstory in a
lot of the history
a lot of characters who are it's made
very clear are now
dead get dealt with and the fact that
they are dead is directly addressed
so you know if you're thinking about
introducing your kid to it have that in
mind but aside from that honestly this
is just a great all-around action show
starting at that age to infinity as far
as i'm concerned there's no age cap on
enjoying this show
and that's why as an animation junkie
i'm definitely addicted did you ever
watch gargoyles who's your favorite
character in all of gargoyles i gotta go
classic i gotta go goliath i can't not
although actually owen kind of runs a
second for me which is maybe an odd
choice but i always liked him so leave
an answer down in the comments let's
talk about it and until next time i'll
be back when i get my fix